مياده ما تفاصيل ما جرى في مخيم جباليا
المشهد يبدو انه يزداد دمويه في مخيم
جباليا اليوم رصدنا مجزره بكل معنى الكلمه
وفق وصف وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه حتى هذه
اللحظه وفي ارقام اوليه لاننا لازلنا في
بدايه استقبال عدد الحالات التي تصل الى
المستشفى الاندونيسيه الاقرب لموقع هذه
المجدره مخيم جبالي حتى الان يتم الحديث
عن اكثر من 400 شخص بين شهيد وجريح معظمهم
من الاطفال والنساء وفق وزاره الداخليه
الفلسطينيه يبدو انه قد استخدم حوالي ست
قنابل كل قنبله بتزن حوالي طن من
المتفجرات اذا نحن نتحدث عن عدد هائل من
القنابل بحجم هائل يستهدف مكانا مكتظا
بالسكان مباني متلاصقه جدا مخيم جباليه هو
من اكثر كثافه بالتالي عدد الضحايا مرجح
ان يكون اكبر من هذا الرقم الذي تم
الاعلان عليه اليوم يوم دموي بكل معنى
الكلمه ايضا هناك مناطق اخرى تعرضت
لاستهداف وهي ايضا احياء سكنيه ذات كثافه
عاليه الوضع في المستشفى الاندونيسي كما
ذكرنا الاقرب لمخيم جباليه و في محيطه هو
ماسوي بكل معنى الكلمه وفق المسؤولين
هناك